European Union environment ministers
will discuss this week new rules to
monitor report on and check carbon
dioxide emissions from maritime
transport the ministers will weigh
whether the proposals to harmonize
surveillance of a key gas responsible
for global warming are balanced and
flexible enough and do not impose a
heavy administrative burden co2
emissions represent about ninety-eight
percent of the greenhouse gases emitted
by ships it's hoped that the EU model
will serve as an example for the
creation of a global system the european
parliament is scheduled to vote on the
scheme in april just before its
legislative term expires the ministers
will also debate ways to stop the spread
of introduced species into the EU which
are causing severe damage to the
environment invasive alien species are
transported outside their normal habitat
through human action this can hurt the
new ecosystem and have serious economic
and social consequences around 12,000
alien species are thought to be found in
Europe around ten to fifteen percent of
them have spread and a costing the EU at
least 12 billion euros each year the new
measures would involve a prevention plan
an early warning and rapid response
system plus steps to manage the species
as they spread